Hey hi everybody I'm Jonathan shots and
today I got another tactical challenge
for you
so when you see the image on your screen
pause your video and we'll see if you
can solve it today's game comes to us
from her any verse Brand X from hungry
1985 in this position it is white to
move so go ahead and pause your video at
this time and let's see if you can solve
today's puzzle in this position it's
clear that black with this pawn on g2 is
very close to promoting so white has to
be really careful with what he does here
you really have to go all-in if you're
white and there's only one move that
wins and white was able to find it and
it forced immediate resignation so if
you haven't found it this is your last
chance to pause in this position white
played the very amazing move Bishop to
g5 and the point is you block the G file
so if they do end up taking your bishop
well now just king g6 is the idea and
you're gonna have made on the back rank
another move the black should probably
try seeing that is to make a queen but
now white gets to play a checkmate so
you can go ahead and pause now if you
want and see if you can find the
checkmate the ending is very satisfying
it starts with a pretty obvious move
Bishop takes f6 and after King g8 h7 and
after King f8 can you spot the mate in
two it starts with rook d8 and now of
course we get to under promote to a
knight with an amazing finishing
position alright I hope you guys enjoyed
that video let me know in the comments
below if you're able to get that one
right as always hit like share subscribe
we'll see you next time for another
tactical challenge